hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
I'm Rachel Smith in today's best picture
close-up we go to an Academy members
screenie where director Steve McQueen
and the cast of 12 years of slave
explore the making of this unforgettable
true story some asked me when was the
first time you came in contact with
slavery and I couldn't remember I think
in a way as a child as a young person to
realize that you know your ancestor some
of your ancestors were slaves and you
was was for me kind of huge thing and to
start of life as a person like that I
think it's kind of I never thought of it
before it must have some sort of effect
on when your outlook on life I wanted
that every footprint of Solomon was your
the audience's footprint what he saw you
saw I just loved that idea of that first
hand account in the book but also as I
turned the pages of the book I had that
same experience everything the heated I
didn't know it was kind of next and I
think that was wanting the audience to
be with Solomon that you were solving
that was very important in it there was
something about Solomon that I fell I
needed to connect with that I actually I
if I could find out about him and
connect to him somehow and I didn't have
to worry about the wider implications of
everything I just had to tell his story
you know Patsy these were her real
circumstances and remembering that
always grounded me because I had the
privilege of doing doing it to
fictionally but she didn't have the
luxury of making her pain precious she
had to work through it and not wallow in
it and I tried to do to you to get to
that place and play her with dignity and
age
see Steve I feel like you have painted
such a realistic and complex landscape a
reality that we haven't seen before that
there's there's enough people and
there's not circumstances that all of us
could imagine ourselves in it whereas
before we would always be at a distance
and something about imagine ourselves in
it and imagining our people that we had
come from in it makes it real allows us
to embrace it and so we can see each
other's point of view more readily
because we have watched watched it
unfold all of us together and hopefully
there will be a common language that we
can start to to listen to each other out
nothing but i think that the word is
love is a huge word this would love and
and it's kind of it's it's the illness
it's always a strange word of using this
one but it's true think the only reason
I'm here you know it's because of love
obviously know some people wanted to
survive and that you know wanted to do
whatever they could for their children
it this what love and I I do believe in
some have this you know that whatever
we're living and now there's possible it
is of of this of going forward and in
the real and it real way because I
otherwise want to make the movie I'm not
it's not about making it down it's
making an up for people to go forward
and to do something about their
environment and in the society for more
behind-the-scenes details about all of
this year's nominated films and go to
Oscar com